mir jetzt zugeschaltet mein kollege
frank schneider frank durst sich jetzt
mit diesem fall beschäftigt was genau
für details kennen wir schon über die
terrorpläne der neonazis die terrorpläne
sind wirklich erschreckend mann hatte
vor muslimen anzugreifen asylbewerber
anzugreifen dieb seine politiker und was
wirklich neue qualität darstellt ist
dass sie in moscheen eindringen wollten
und du sagst eben in eine moschee
möglicherweise sogar in viele maschinen
und man hatte das aktive geplant man
wollte wird nicht in maschinen
eindringen in kleineren ortschaften die
abgelegen liegen damit die polizei in
dieser schnell vor ort ist und das
schnelle eingreifen kann und dass man
sich mal vorstellen
wirklich diese planung zu haben man muss
man kann möglichst viele menschen töten
weil polizei braucht eine gewisse zeit
bis sie eingreifen kann und die täter
hatten und das kennen wir bisher
wirklich nur von islamistischen
attentätern ihren eigenen tod eingeplant
sie hatten also eine art schon gesagt
ich habe meiner freundin schon gesagt
irgendwann auch mich vielleicht nicht
wieder
das weiß nur aus den abgehörten chats
und telefonaten und das ist wirklich
eine ganz neue qualität
sie wollten wirklich massaker anrichten
wir wollten möglichst viele menschen
töten
es gibt auch einen v mann in diesem fall
welche rolle hat er gespielt vor allem
jetzt bei dem zugriff am wochenende ja
unser stand ist dass dieser v-mann
erstmals dieser gruppe dazu gehörte und
er hat sich dann im oktober entweder
anvertraut oder die polizei hat ihn
angesprochen
offenbar war ihm das dann irgendwann
alles zu heiß war merkte die meinen ist
wirklich ernst und er hat sich dann der
polizei im oktober an vertraut seit
september wusste man von dieser ziele
man hat die polizei damit informationen
versorgt ist offenbar weiter zu den
treffen denn es gab ja auch 13
sogenannte beschuldigte in diesem
verfahren zwölf sitze nur acht einer
nicht und da scheint dieser v mann zu
sein
das heißt erst von der polizei insofern
ist die gruppe eingeschlossen er war in
der gruppe ist dann von der polizei so
gesehen umgedreht worden und das war in
diesem fall natürlich sehr gut für die
polizei dadurch waren sie über alle
schritte informiert man muss zum
beispiel auch wissen mal den letzten
treffen vor gut einer woche samstags in
minden
wir lagen schon mehrere
spezialeinsatzkommandos in
bereitstellung weil man da nicht wusste
ob sie
möglicherweise schon von diesem treffen
aus losschlagen wollen von diesem
treffen aus möglicherweise schon
losfahren und anschläge begehen wollten
als es dann nicht passiert ist aber noch
ein paar tage gewartet noch weitere
beweise gesammelt und dann erst
losgeschlagen eben wissen wie groß ist
die gefahr in deutschland von
rechtsextremen terror bern gerade
christchurch gehört dass das vorbild
gewesen sein soll rechtsextremer
terrorist auf der ganzen welt ein
problem wie akut ist das hier in
deutschland
naja wie akut die gefahr das haben wir
ja alle schmerzlich erfahren müssen als
das in halle passiert ist das war ja so
dieser erste rechtsextreme anschlag den
alle fürchtet hat man muss ja vorstellen
mit den islamisten gibt es immer so
genannte lohmen wulff als dieser
einsamen wölfe die einfach losschlagen
das war auch in halle so ein täter er
hat sich selbst radikalisiert auch über
das internet das muss man eben auch
sagen die vernetzung findet europaweit
auch irgendwas internet statt es ist
heute viel viel einfacher und der hat
dann losgeschlagen und das ist jetzt
hier bei dieser zelle etwas neues was
die polizei aber schon länger befürchtet
hat dass sich gruppen zusammen schließt
man hat sich im internet kennen man
unterstützt sich gegenseitig in diesen
radikalen meinungen und dann ist man
plötzlich der meinung wir müssen etwas
tun
viele sprechen seit der flüchtlingskrise
imponieren staatsversagen das gefühl zu
haben der staatswald sagt der staat hat
nicht mehr im griff und jetzt müssen wir
was machen wir kennen ja auch alle die
vorfälle
das ist auch in reihen der polizei auch
teilweise der spezialeinheiten teilweise
weil der bundeswehr immer wieder fällt
die ksk dieses spezialkommando in den
streitkräften was auch in afghanistan
und sonstwo eingesetzt wird das sind die
absoluten elite soldaten dass die immer
wieder möglicherweise in ihren reihen
rechtsradikale tendenzen haben und das
ist die große gefahr
die bewaffneten sich die haben zugang zu
waffen der fdp-politiker sagte ja gerade
das ist das problem wir müssen sehen
dass die keine waffen haben aber das ist
ein großes problem es gibt menschen die
haben zugang zu waffen sei es aus
behörden sei es sportschützen reichs
bürger zum beispiel sind sehr häufig
auch sportschützen und haben deshalb
rechtmäßigen zugang zu waffen und ihnen
diese waffen wegzunehmen es war ein sehr
schwieriger prozess in deutschland und
das dauert und da muss man sicherlich
überlegen ob man da nicht schneller
eingreifen kann wollte noch einen satz
auch zu einem beteiligten polizei
mitarbeiter der in haben hier nordrhein
westfalen festgenommen wurde ich zitiere
mal was er
planet gelegt hat wir müssen von zeit zu
zeit terroranschläge verüben bei denen
unbeteiligte menschen sterben dadurch
lässt sich der gesamte staat und die
gesamte bevölkerung lenken und das ist
eben dieser krankenwagen dieser kranke
hast wir müssen einen bürgerkrieg
auslösen damit die menschen merken was
hier bei uns los ist was uns droht und
durch diese eskalation in ihren augen
eine verbesserung herbeiführen wie die
aussehen soll ist mir allerdings sehr
rätselhaft
die polizei hatte schon länger
befürchtet hast du gerade gesagt aber
wie gut sind ermittlungsbehörden
wirklich informiert über pläne von
rechtsextremen gruppen die sich wie
jetzt in diesem fall im netz zusammen
zum beispiel zusammenfinden der v mann
hast ja auch schon gesagt war jetzt eher
glück für die polizei und nicht weil sie
ihn selber eingeschleust haben kommt
unsere polizei wirklich hinterher was in
diesem konkreten fall haben die
hervorragende arbeit man muss ja
wirklich sagen sie haben die schon im
visier gehabt bevor der v mann sozusagen
umgedreht wurde also dieses mitglied der
gruppe was hat für die polizei eben
informationen gesammelt hat und man muss
eben sagen es wird im internet extrem
viel überwacht der eine war reichs
bürger war polizeibekannt dadurch schon
auf dem schirm der kollege kam hat aber
gesagt der kopf der bande wurde schon
überwacht von einem eklat falls er
irgendwie losschlagen
damit man ihn im griff behält ob das
immer so gelingen wird ist natürlich
fraglich weil diese gruppen können sich
im internet vernetzen ist alles sehr
anonym die flut der daten die flut
dieser ganzen posting sind so gigantisch
und wenn sich kunden bilden über das
netz nicht viel gemacht wird dann ist
für die polizei natürlich total
schwierig und wir haben ja in jüngster
vergangenheit immer wieder fälle gehabt
auch in ostdeutschland
es gab die us society es gab eben diese
revolution chemnitz immer wieder gruppen
auch häufig hooligans beteiligt bekannte
rechtsextreme die sich dann zusammen
schließen in diesem sinne wir müssen
endlich was machen jetzt schlagen wir
los und ob die polizei wirklich immer
auf alle im blick haben wird ist leider
fraglich deswegen halte ich die gefahr
momentan mindestens genau so hoch so
einen rechtsradikalen anschlag für einen
islamistischen in deutschland